representative George Santos has been
expelled from Congress it's shocking
because George Santos had one heck of a
resume he's the grandson of Holocaust
Survivors the former star of the baroo
college volleyball team a financial whiz
kid who worked on Wall Street an animal
lover with experience in the nonprofit
sector a producer on the Broadway
smashit Spider-Man turn off the dark and
an actor who appeared on Hannah Montana
his life story has been touched by some
of the biggest events of this era he
lost four employees in the Pulse
Nightclub shooting in Orlando his
5-year-old niece was kidnapped by
Chinese communist at a New York
playground his mother was the first
female executive at a major financial
institution but like others who worked
in finance in Manhattan she was
tragically murdered on 911 Santos has
gone through more in his scant 25 years
on this planet than many have
experienced in an entire lifetime as
some have described him he's for a scump
but evil oh wait absolutely none of the
things that I've just said are true in
any way Santos's Grandparents were from
Brazil his mother was a cook living in
Brazil on September 11th and thankfully
she lived for 15 more years he didn't
attend brute college or any college it
seems he wasn't a Broadway producer his
financial expertise consists mainly of
credit card theft none of his employees
were murdered his niece was never
kidnapped he's Catholic not Jewish he
stole puppies from the Amish and I could
go on however George dealer Santos
finally has an accomplishment he can
hang his sweater vest on on December 1st
2023 he became just the sixth lawmaker
in US history and the first Republican
to be expelled from the house and you
might be laughing now but unlike most of
the members who voted to expel him
Santos really will go down in American
history so today let's talk about how to
get legally expelled from the House of
Representatives now all those Lies made
Santos a fabulous but not necessarily a
criminal as we've talked about many
times on this channel uh politicians can
lie to American citizens often without
repercussion however on May 10th Santos
was indicted on 13 criminal counts of
wire fraud unlawful monetary
transactions over $10,000 theft of
public money and false statements as
scow Al Spencer explained at the time it
contains 13 criminal counts including
wire fraud unlawful monetary
transactions over $10,000 theft of
public money and false statements and in
October prosecutors hit Santos with 10
more accounts of conspiracy to commit
offenses against the us including wire
fraud making false statements to the
Federal Election Commission falsifying
records aggravated identity theft and
access device fraud the criminal charges
finally prompted the house Ethics
Committee to start an investigation and
the committee released a 56-page report
on November 16th it says Santos stole
money from his campaign reported
fictitious loans deceived donors and
engaged in fraudulent business dealings
the report says Santos used that money
to cover his personal expenses now
Santos has a pension for wearing
sweaters under his Blazers but he
apparently used campaign funds at luxury
clothing retailers like Hermes although
I've yet to see him wear anything that
cost over $4,000 as detailed in the
report Santos visited a plastic surgeon
and spent almost $3,000 on Botox which
may or may not have worked he used
campaign funds for other Medical Spa
visits incling including $1,500 purchase
on the campaign debit card at murza
Aesthetics and a $1,400 charge at
virtual Skin Spa he spent $3,300 in
campaign money at an Airbnb in the
Hamptons and $2,200 in Atlantic City he
spent money on only fans despite
claiming that he had no idea what that
site was just discover what only fans
was about 3 weeks ago when it was bought
up in a discussion in my office do and I
was very I was oblivious to the whole
concept now we don't know for sure what
he purchased on only fans but hopefully
soon we'll find out out the Naked Truth
Expos every detail and lay bare the
Stark reality the Ethics Committee also
accused Santos of stealing campaign
donors identities and racking up
thousands of dollars in unauthorized
charges on their credit cards to benefit
his campaign and himself personally this
misconduct includes defrauding other
members of Congress and their families
Ohio Republican Max Miller said Santos
quote had charged my personal credit
card and the personal card of my mother
for contribution amounts that exceeded
FEC limits neither my mother nor I
approve these charges or were aware of
them the charges resulted in Miller
spending quote tens of thousands of
dollars in legal fees to resolve the
situation Miller claims he had seen a
list of 400 people including other
Republican house members who Santos also
defrauded in this way the day before the
vote uh Miller and Santos exchanged
barbs about this with Miller saying you
sir are a crook I know I should direct
my comments to the chair Santos fired
back by referencing accusations that
Miller assaulted his girlfriend my
colleague wants to come up here call me
a crook same colleague who's accused of
being a woman beater just a real classy
dude there now obviously Santos is going
to need a good lawyer for the doj's
prosecution but if you want a great
lawyer my firm the eagle team can help
if you've been in a car crash suffered a
data breach or have a worker's comp
issue we can represent you or help find
you the right attorney it's important to
talk to a lawyer right away so you can
get the best representation and find out
what your options are so just click on
the link in the description for free
consultation with my team right away
because you don't just need a legal team
you need the eagle team team the link is
down below uh now the Constitution
grants each house of Congress the power
to quote punish its members for
disorderly behavior and with the
concurrence of two-thirds expel a member
expulsion is the process of ejecting a
member of Congress after that person has
been elected and seated the ethics
committees have jurisdiction to
investigate the conduct of members that
might reflect poorly on the body of
Congress uh in which they serve during
the Constitutional Convention the
founding fathers never discussed the
type of misconduct that would warrant
expulsion they were more concerned with
providing a restraint on that power
hence the 2/3 majority requirement there
wasn't much debate about the meaning of
the expulsion Clause leaving future
Americans with the responsibility
figuring out how it applies and while
the founding fathers probably never
contemplated a member of Congress using
campaign funds to buy an only fan
subscription that probably qualifies as
something that uh can lead to expulsion
now the Supreme Court and lower federal
courts have not decided a case about the
expulsion of a member of Congress
because members who weren't expelled
haven't challenged their expulsions in
court though some members like James
trafficing and Charlie Wrangle sought
legislative review of disciplinary
proceedings that were invoked pursuant
to the expulsion Clause but courts
demurred because of the political
question Doctrine now we've talked about
the political question Doctrine in the
past most recently in the video about
whether Trump is disqualified from the
presidency uh political questions are
controversies that are so politically
charged that the courts shouldn't get
involved preferring to leave it up to
the legislature which would almost
certainly apply in the case of expulsion
then there's also the separation of
powers issue the three branches of
government would rather police
themselves then have the other branches
meddle in disciplinary matters so
Congress says it has the sole right to
discipline its members while the Supreme
Court insists that Congress has no right
to impose an Ethics code on the justices
the Supreme Court has discussed the
expulsion power in dicta from time to
time for example in 1972 former Senator
Daniel Brewster challenged his bribery
indictment on the basis that his conduct
was protected by the speech and debate
clause the Court held that the
legislative privilege does not Encompass
all legislative acts and Brewster uh
could be prosecuted the court observed
that when it comes to discipline and
expulsion quote an accused member is
judged by no specifically articulated
standards and is at the mercy of an
almost unbridled discretion of the
charging body that functions at once as
accuser prosecutor judge and jury from
whose decision there is no established
right to review now some lawyers argue
it's unconstitutional to expel someone
for conduct that happened before they
were elected particularly if the
member's conduct was known by the voters
when they elected that person they say
that conflicts with article 1's mandate
that the house quote shall be composed
of members chosen by the people now a
local newspaper the NorthShore leader
uncovered many of Santos's lies before
he was elected to the House of
Representatives but I don't think you
can compare Santos with congressmen
whose constituents knew they were
big-time Crooks or were already in
prison for example Ohio Democrat James
traffing uh was convicted of taking many
different bribes and traff managed to
get 20% of the vote while serving a
federal prison term Republican Klay
Higgins said that Santos was elected by
the people and their decision should be
sacren but New York Republican Nick Lola
was having none of this he didn't work
where he said he did he didn't go to
school where he said he did he's far
from Rich he isn't Jewish and his mother
was not in the South Tower during 911 so
the argument that New Yorkers voted
George Santos in and that we should wait
until November of 2024 for voters to
decide his fate is inherently flawed
since voters weren't given a chance in
the first in the first chance to
determine who they were actually voting
for now some members who voted not to
expel Santos say they did it because
didn't get the due process that he would
get in a court of law what I'm finding
fault with is that our members have
forgotten that everybody is afforded due
process under law not due process under
the Ethics Committee but the
Constitution is clear that Congress
doesn't have to wait until someone is
criminally convicted in cases of
expulsion or impeachment and of course
the Constitution doesn't say that the
phrase High crimes and misdemeanors or
disorderly Behavior actually mean
criminal convictions the only other
possible theoretical limitation on the
expulsion power is if it's used to
trample on a member's individ idual
right so if Congress expelled someone
because of that person's race or
religion they might have a decent legal
argument but that certainly doesn't
apply here now Congress does not use its
expulsion power very often before Santos
only 15 members and five members of the
House had ever been expelled from Office
the earliest expulsion case was in 1797
when Senator William Blount quote
concocted a scheme for Indians and
frontiersmen to attack Spanish Florida
and Louisiana in order to transfer those
territories to Great Britain Blount
wrote all this down in a letter uh which
president Adams used to get him expelled
as for the other expulsions 17 were
related to the Civil War and in 1980
Pennsylvania Democrat Michael Myers no
relation was expelled for taking a bribe
James traffickin who I mentioned before
was expelled in 2002 and that brings us
up to today the Santos resolution passed
311 to 114 despite Republican house
leadership's attempts to save Santos
that includes speaker Mike Johnson who
voted against the resolution Johnson is
facing questions about his own finances
and since his election to the house in
2016 none of Johnson's Financial
disclosures have included a bank account
and as for the other corruption train
wreck in Congress senator Bob Menendez
fellow Democrat John fedman says it's
time for the senator from Egypt to go
and if you are going to expel Santos how
can you allow to somebody like Menendez
to remain in the Senate and things came
full circle when fedan hired Santos to
make a sarcastic Cameo urging Menendez
to stay strong and stay in congress hey
Bobby uh look I don't think I need to
tell you but these people that want to
make you get in trouble and want to kick
you out and make you run away you make
him put up or shut up you stand your
ground sir and don't get bogged down by
all the haters out there stay strong
Merry Christmas now there will be a
special election to fill Santos's seat
and Santos's criminal trial is scheduled
for September 2024 now the expulsion of
George Santos has been covered
extensively by more than 300 news
outlets 36% of the reporting is coming
from the left and 20% is coming from the
right and if you compare the headlines
you'll start to see some interesting
framing on the left you have Outlets
saying that he was finally expelled and
third times the charm with reference to
Santos expulsion while in right news
outlets usually stick to just expel
these word changes are subtle but they
play a big role in how readers perceive
the story the first set of words might
imply that we knew Santos was a fraud
all along and that it was a long time
coming well the second set of words
provides an understated account that
downplays some of his malfeasant now all
this is possible thanks to today's
sponsor ground news a website and app
developed by a former NASA engineer on a
mission to give readers an easy data
driven objective way to read the news
every story comes with a quick visual
breakdown of the political bias
factuality and ownership of the sources
reporting all backed by ratings from
three Independent News monitoring
organizations I especially like the new
ground news comparison feature which
highlights specific differences between
left and right reporting for the story
on Santos's expulsion you can see that
left leaning Outlets tended to focus on
his use of campaign funds for personal
expenses while the right presents
factual information about the expulsion
without priority prioritizing loaded or
emphatic language ground news also has a
blind spot feed which highlights stories
that are disproportionately covered by
one side of the political Spectrum these
tools are so important so we don't live
in an echo chamber or get misled by
subtle and sometimes not so subtle
language in the news so give ground news
A Try by click on the link that's on
screen right now or down in the
description and just for the holidays
through December 28th you can get their
biggest sale of the year right now you
can get a 40% discount on ground news's
Vantage subscription their Vantage
subscription includes unlimited access
to all ground news features and with the
subscription is only $5 a month or you
can start with our Pro Plan Which is
less than $1 and it's the biggest deal
of the year so go to ground. news/
legale Eagle or click on the link below
and you'll get a 4% discount on
unlimited access to their app website
and newsletters all for just $5 a month
after that click on this link over here
for more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court